tonight you can tell that you're in pain
but that you are a fighter and you're
gonna keep going well fonzo got you with
the tears didn't he I teared up right
now big night emotional night on both
Dancing with the Stars and the boys yeah
these TV competitions are getting very
exciting emotional as we just said and
we were backstage at though we're
definitely gonna rest and no drinks for
you I didn't want yeah I need I need
just a little number just a little
number look at his neck his / neck from
doing this trick
just a lot of bruises that's so many
resist I pulled something yesterday it's
been pretty bad I'm hoping I can make it
to the rest of this week they are beat
up but number one in prime time dancing
semi-finals averaged more than 14 and a
half million viewers while the voice
averaged just under 11 million well just
hours from now the ranks of the boys
will get thinner two of the top 12 will
go home the only big mess up last night
came from Luke wait coach Pharrell told
us no big deal Luke had a moment where
the track came apart for a second but he
held it down I mean his recovery it's
awesome short of singing an entire song
as well as you can singing most of it
seems to be the next best thing